[Music]
all right well now what is next for
Mariah Carey she's moving on after that
New Year's Eve a nightmare but Rach need
host Ryan Seacrest finally speaks out
things happen on live TV it's just
unfortunate that it comes to all of this
Ryan's comments come after Mariah's
seemed to throw shade at him with her
most recent statement saying quote Dick
Clark would not have let an artist go
through that I immediately physically
moved from that stage to head back down
several blocks to the other stage right
I didn't have a visual Mariah's manager
of 20 months Estella balázs Nick off has
waged nearly a week long war with the
show's producers but now Tommy Mottola
seems to be calling Stella out Kerry's
ex-husband and former manager urged
meaning to quote hire more seasoned and
respected professionals Stella fired
back calling Tommy a quote a relic
you're a fiercely protective of your
client and she's my client yeah she's my
producing partner which I joke and say
she's my sister wife we are right or die
I have her back as the new guiding force
behind Mimi Stella who is also a former
reality show producer has certainly
shaken things up this year allowing
cameras to film the divas wild antics
for her II document are we getting
another season I don't know because
we'll see we just finished filming -
Mariah's big tease for the rest of the
season this make out with new boyfriend
and backup dancer Bryan Tanaka that's
caused a lot of both among the fact yes
you'll have to just keep watching to see
where the where the kiss came from an
extra Mimi in 2017 more music she's
touring with Lana Ritchie as a special
guest
hopefully a potential duet with Lionel
and more TV we got this exclusive we
have a secret project you have a
scripted drama that we are developing
that has not been announced I'm about
Mariah's life that's gonna be incredibly
poignant
you